et bien la commission mixte paritaire a
échoué nous avons un désaccord de fond
avec
les députés avec la majorité de
l'assemblée nationale
ces désaccords de fond il porte sur deux
points principaux le premier la date du
30 et du 3 juillet dévolues par un
sommet national comme étant le délai
ultime hockey pendant lequel le
gouvernement pour agir en clair sans
contrôle du parlement c'est ça la
réalité le deuxième sujet c'est la
vaccination notamment dans les écoles de
la connaissance corps ont lentement les
médecins scolaires mais surtout les
gaiters écoles de la station ax in ad
des enfants qu'ils ont en charge
mais le point majeur reste cette date de
fin juillet comment accepter que le
parlement se dessaisisse de ses moyens
de contrôle certes il ya une suspension
à la fin du mois de février mais en
aucun cas elle n'interdit aux paroles au
sénat et à la social de se réunir et pas
difficulté lexus sont toujours en
session ordinaire et part de ce fait
vouloir
déposséder le parce que le parlement de
son pouvoir contrôler constitue pour le
sénat est très largement pour la
majorité du sénat
un désaccord profonde